i could be way off but if ryan hears
this like you know it's a good story as
you shut up um so it was a sister
um went out on a date with this guy in
idaho yeah right
she goes out on the date and and she's
having an okay time but she's like every
time like this guy is like looking
through me she's like i felt like
extremely uncomfortable that i'm on a
date with this guy like she's he's
looking through me and he's just like
strange and she's like i got that like
chill that like a you know woman can get
or a person can get when they're like
i'm in the presence of someone sinister
and i don't want to be near this and he
had picked her up from their house
so she's like oh i'm gonna i just gotta
make a phone call i'm not feeling too
long he's like i'll drive you home and
she's like no no like you know just like
give me a second calls her because it
was you know the 70s pay phone calls her
brother i think their older brother and
says hey you got to come pick me up
right now i'm creeped out but this guy
come pick me up wait in the bathroom so
she doesn't see absolutely go back the
brother and she says call this he says
call the pay phone when you're here you
know i'll listen for it calls his
favorite brother say hey i'm outside
gets in the car
goes home doesn't go back to the to the
restaurant you know doesn't go back to
the table just [ __ ] i'm away from
this guy
so then the brother at six o'clock in
the morning the next morning goes out
because he had some kind of like paper
out or some kind of early morning job
and the somebody runs out of the bushes
oh like like away like away like but he
was waiting there all night runs out of
the bushes and he's like who the [ __ ]
and then he yells up to the sister he
says oh somebody run out of bushes is
this a guy from last night and then he
she sees the car peeling out
and whatever and sees it so they call
the police
and uh uh say you know um hey there's
some weird guy whatever whatever
whatever
weird guy and just wanna you know he's
you know he's creepy and whatever he
says what's his name he said ted bundy
[Laughter]
yeah
insane and this is me
before ted bundy was famous he wasn't he
had killed women already it was the open
mic years
[Music]
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]